I live in La.
Three people in your friends wound up
here and I always visit and then I would
drive through the Hollywood hills and
see these homes and I was thinking,
I need to do this. You
know, I need to be here.
For some people they prefer to sit
behind a desk from eight to five.
I fall asleep.
It's all about energy.
I drive a lot, man. Um,
you guys sat in from like Pasadena
or way to thousand oaks to Hollywood,
Beverly Hills and you got good reviews.
It good polls,
but you see why they pay the price.
I'm from the island of Guam
smile in 26 miles long.
All my siblings are back home.
Just me out here.
I tell my clients that I'm 25
but I am early twenties.
The good thing is,
is the clients that I work
with are all very young people.
Like they're all kind of doing the same
thing as me because I utilize social
media. The people that I connect with
on, there are younger people who are,
you know, you tubers or music artists or
music producers. Every client, you know,
they want a house in a different area.
So I'm all over the place. You know,
I'm running from Venice, Santa Monica all
the way, you know, it's even silver lake,
12 pills a day. It'd be, takes you
half an hour to clean the pool.
It's definitely 20 bucks.
You can say it's about
managing time because if you
stay out of your morning for
12 hours a day, you're pretty much
making less than minimum wage.
I think the hours that
I put in for both jobs,
the most 16 the minimum 12
hours, I say like, Dude. Yeah,
and that's just to survive in California,
you know,
most of the deals I do are like 5 million
and under mostly because a lot of my
clients are younger.
Do you see the big purchases
that are like 20 million plus?
Those ones are usually older people,
you know, it just makes sense.
You've been on the planet longer, you've
made more money, you can afford it.
I mean my office,
we have the $188 million
listing up in Bel Air.
They were really trying to get
Jay Z and Beyonce to buy the home.
They thought it was perfect for them.
They have been trying to connect with
every single billionaire in the world.
That's quite a risk you're taking
kneepads cause as the day goes by when
you keep kneeling down on your knees
about padding,
it tends to hurt.
Hey,
how's it going
dude?
So this is the asset tag.
This is the chlorine tank.
You mix chlorine and acid together.
You can chemically make mustard gas.
I once mix Corrine and acid in the wrong
tank on accident and you can endure
like burn marks. But inside your
system from the smoke itself,
you learn your lessons
after each things happen.
Properties when they're forced sale
and you get commissioned and it's,
if you're representing the buyer,
the standard is typically 2.5%
of the purchase price. Honestly.
How much do you think this house is?
It's like a town house or is it Venice?
One and a half,
3.3
wipe provides it for me,
gives me everything that I needed
to try to keep me safe out here.
Her name is April.
I worked at the UFC gym in 2015 for her
at the gym was like a getaway for her to
go relax. Why people
do that, you know, man,
I I if I didn't meet her,
I'll probably say I used to sleep
in the back of the gym, the UFC gym.
Like hadn't, you know, I'll
wake up, train, train people,
um, teaching class and that's it.
You know, that's like a bachelors,
a lifestyle.
Like now as I try to help her pursue
her career first and also like try to
secure financial for her and
my, my two cats, you know, like,
um,
it makes me happy.
Are you going to,
that's the goal,
you know, and you don't even have to live
in it and you can make money from it.
I had a client who I, I showed
him a, a house in studio city,
the La Galaxy soccer team did a photo
shoot at the house for one night and then
paid them $30,000.
It's right now we're going to see
Catherine and she's leasing this home, um,
for about $14,000 a month in commission,
somewhere around 7,000.
You know Elise still you make a whole
lot less than a sale but so one time,
7,000, right, exactly. And then,
and then in this case scenario,
you know, I found her this lease
and now this lease is turned,
has turned into a sale.
You know,
cause I'm going to be finding
her property to buy now.
Hey you
I know.
Try trying to like three or four.
That's how much after,
I mean I was thinking
like the foothills stadio,
Cindy Sherman oaks. So you're on the
backside of the hill. That's fine.
It's way cheaper and that's fine.
You can drive down to Ventura or he
can drive Laurel Canyon. It's La.
I have to drive through this
all the time. Yeah, we all do.
So used to it by now and get them, make
sure you have a place for all those cars.
We want to be to at least park two
to three cars in a garage and um,
at least be able to put
maybe like four cars outside,
which is why it's important to
like this one right here. Oh,
that looks nice. Not have a pool.
It does. And picky, but I'm not,
I know what I like the dream client.
Well that's good. I'm glad I'm the tree
Kia
can to complain. They'll watch
you. They'll look out the window,
had a lady,
she pretty much watch you and to make
sure you do everything that's on that
checklist. How did that
go when gray, you know,
it makes my job so much easier when my
clients are actually my friends and she
said she'll spend up to 4 million.
What is 2.5% of 4 million?
I love tender Greens. It's so
good. And it's not even expensive.
I don't watch very many interviewers,
but I'd definitely uh,
I've always watched Danny.
It's videos.
We're going to go meet up with him
and this house has a nightclub in it.
So it could be interesting.
Life out here is different now.
Like you go to island slow,
everyone's chilling here. Everyone's
moving my salary back there, it was like,
what?
15,000 a year
on a bad email. One of my deals just
close. So that was coke get some coffee.
So this was actually like
small, you know, 2.5% of it.
It's like roughly around $10,000.
It's definitely not bad for not
even stepping foot on this property.
Are you doing man? Yeah.
One more. And one more
coworker she's checking.
You know that usually maybe like
eight how many more poles you got man,
this conversation, you know,
cause like it's not a lonely job,
but it's just like either listening
to music or you talked to your other
coworkers.
He know it's just a dream job.
But I like to work in animation,
but I don't know how to draw,
so I'm not really going to
try to pursue that. You know,
you're like in your mind
you can configure it.
It's down to the very last screw or very
less sketch when when you actually take
paper to pencil,
it doesn't come out man.
No, you guys are excited about this.
The good thing is it's only $23,
but I don't know how I got,
I got a parking ticket.
Do you literally look at the sign
and it says turn wheels to curb?
I did not know.
That was even a thing.
Dude in my hometown to Michaela,
my dad sells yachts
and he's built and design
boats because whole life, um,
which is how I kind of first got
into that and then I was like, man,
this is pretty boring. Did you start out
working for your dad's company? Yeah,
I started,
I started working under him,
like following them around and learning,
you know,
and then I just didn't feel right.
You know,
my family back home, you
know, they're simple people.
I have two sisters and one brother.
The two old days,
they're not as vicious as a t young is.
We all have our,
our reasons,
what we do and why we do.
And one of the reason why I moved out
here is because I wanted a better life.
How much is this for
sale? Three. Three now.
Yeah. I'm just looking at this house
right now. 3 million up in the hills.
I want a little flavor, you know,
besides just plain wires does a bad day.
You're looking at approximately throat
and rotate your shoulder phone, phone.
Oh yeah, they got the movie theater and
here to here. You got some full on bar.
I don't even drink. What Papa of
move in. Move Out to jab, cross,
move in and move out.
Do you want to go home and get it like
a foot massage man, after your own day?
Like this
smile be even more busy.
It's all about energy. Male,
like having good energy in a
class. Pushing people, keep
them going. And it's fun.
It's crazy to think where am I
going to be in five, 10 years?
Ooh.
And it's just the most wild
thought to me cause I don't know.
No one yet from Guam has
ever fought in for a belt.
My goal is to just make it onto one of
the fighting organization doing glory.
Man, I'd love to stand and bang all
around it. It was just a great day,
just grinding away,
15 hour shift today, you
know? But it was overall good.
Any job is great,
but like are you going to wake up someone
next you that loves you for who you
are? It's not about being
happy in the end, man.
Where's it at you? Hey, where's
the remote? Put It on some jubilee.